this episode looks like a hard one for
teddy
she hasn't been sleeping she has a lot
going on for her
emotionally what what kind of journey
is ahead for her you know i think it's
really incredible i just kept hearing
from all the fans like when are we gonna
see
what is going on with teddy and this
episode is really sort of a beautiful
story to understand and it's not an
excuse because i
also was a little upset at teddy but i
think it really
explains why teddy did
what she did you know she had a lot of
loss and i feel like that is a very
relatable thing right now but
unfortunately hers just manifested in
this um
really awful behavior and uh
and it really talks about the
differences and and
everyone has a different form of ptsd
and how
you know and how it comes out and i
think what's interesting is
you know owens character has had his own
story
of ptsd and so i think that hopefully we
we work towards forgiveness which i
think is also a really beautiful
storyline
so hopefully we'll get some peace after
this episode
definitely and it's it's also just like
an incredible
episode even though it's a very heavy
storyline there's some really
fun uh crazy crazy scenes
at the end of last week's episode we saw
owen
literally carry teddy home
do you think that that sign that there's
hope for that relationship or what do
you think
that was i mean i'm like a hopeless
romantic
me kim so like i you know i they've been
through so
much together i kind of secretly am
always hoping that
um you know that they work it out we
don't know where they're gonna go
but what i do know is that they have an
unbreakable friendship
even though it's it's sort of they're at
rock bottom right now
and to me that's also really interesting
we're not perfect
and to be able to have a friendship like
teddy and owen
um it's so beautiful i mean literally
and figuratively he he
he lifts her up out of sort of like the
depths of her
darkness and is is getting
her to a better place and that's also
what this episode and
you know meredith's in it and some other
surprises
are in it um so i really think it's
about their friendship first and
and then actually i did get to see
another episode coming up and so i don't
know
we'll see i have to keep tuning in i do
want to talk about
all the surprises that you teased but
very quickly
with the loss of deluca we're once again
reminded that
no one is safe in terms of cast members
should we be worried for teddy i don't
know
i mean you know you never know i think
you have to tune in i mean i just think
it's such a beautiful story and
um and i i really feel that the fans
have been
wanting this of wanting to kind of see
uh
teddy be able to redeem herself in
whatever way she can because i know that
you know we went really far with her and
it's
really hard to come back from that kind
of awful
cheating just cheating period but i you
know
i i i i am hopeful
for teddy and that she has uh you know
a long journey to to gain forgiveness
but i hope that we get to see that
i hope so too sarah drew has been back
on set
this week what can you reveal about
her return i am nothing
nothing and nothing like nothing
otherwise you really do have like a
bullseye on you
no that i mean look this year is i just
think
with all of the sort of difficult
that all the hardship that we've all had
to go through and some more than
others i feel like krista has really
brought
so many sort of like shining
bright lights for us to look forward to
and
sarah drew is just such a like a shining
light
and so talented and gifted and an
amazing person and their relationship is
so good and
you know i mean for for kristin to be
able to figure out
how to bring these people back i think
is a really
uh hopeful and exciting and
fun and uplifting uh way to kind of
uh shine the light into where where
we've all come from this last
year yeah should should jpro fans
feel excited for what's to come can you
say that
um yeah because sarah drew is coming
back
and there relay their chemistry and
their relationship is just
incredible so yes i think
the show i mean no show is to be missed
from now until season finale because
there's just
it's there's just so many surprises and
um just wonderful things you keep
mentioning
surprises and every cast member that
i've talked to says that there is a
bigger moment
than patrick dempsey's return ahead
what could be bigger than that i like
the way you
can i can't i can't
i like the way you like different angles
let's see
i'm trying here i just will say stay
tuned is there a bigger is there a
bigger return than his though can you
say that
i don't know is it catherine heigl is it
sandra oh
is it kyler lee i don't know
i i really feel like this season is just
a beautiful season and we've been so
lucky
um and are so lucky to have the writers
for sure but like the casts that
you know the way the writers have
figured out to have these
amazing cast members uh return
and the story lines and so i'll just
i'll say it again stay tuned
i do want to talk briefly about patrick
dempsey i know you can't say
a ton but in the last episode we we saw
this really heartbreaking moment between
him and and meredith talking about their
children and how he's been watching down
on them
are there more heartwarming i guess
conversations to come between the two of
them
wow very specific
um i
i actually i don't i don't know a lot i
don't i don't know the answer to that
one that one all
i'm just gonna i don't know ellen
recently said that she doesn't know if
this is the final season she said that
they're in the middle of deciding
if this is the end or not the end
how likely is it in your opinion that
this is the final season
that i that is a i have no idea
you know we just literally come to work
and we're so grateful
to be at work every day and um it really
it forces you to be even more present
because you just
you don't know do you think there's more
story to tell especially in terms of
teddy
oh i 100 think there are many
stories to tell and um again we are so
lucky to have such incredible writers
but
i you know definitely i feel like we've
sort of just begun
with teddy and uh and her sort of whole
journey ahead
um and you know sort of how once you've
hit rock bottom
there's only up so yeah i definitely
feel like there's a lot of stories to
tell and i don't know i feel like if we
were to come back next year
it'll definitely be sort of a
you know us all wanting to kind of come
out of this pandemic and
um and and very joyful
you